we're keeping the turkey train on the
track with a special edition of
thanksgiving food news
oh we got a new sound there yeah oh i
like it you do a good turkey sound don't
you
thank you
you're welcome um okay joining us for
the feast we have a very special guest
in our audience
she worked in her local school system
for 23 years and now she's a grandma
enjoying the retired life and she's a
special pen pal of mine we met through
our dear drew segment please welcome
linda mora
oh my god
so much fun and exciting to meet both of
you so excited thank you thank you
i love you guys well will you join us
for today's food news i would love to it
looks like you're all set up you got a
tv tray and everything
[Applause]
linda you didn't have to bring a turkey
with you
or possibly a uh well ross what's our
first court well the first course is
we're trying trader joe's stuffing
flavored kettle chips the potato chips
that taste like stuffing all right here
we go ready so
yeah
oh my gosh
[Applause]
oh my god
yum so it's everything you love about
stuffing and everything you love about a
potato chip
in one
all right well now that we've had our
appetizer we're gonna pump up the volume
with the main course the turducken
now walk me through a turducken okay
this franken bird is of course a turkey
stuffed with a duck stuffed with a
chicken
[Music]
ah
yeah it's
it seems a little
what's the word against nature
[Laughter]
well i have actually never tried a
turducken me either linda i've never
tried it well then we can bond over this
moment
um because
well here we go and the good news is you
can now
get it delivered to your door
this one comes from aaron's gourmet
right here in new york
um let's dig in
delicious
[Applause]
it is like you know a triple
trifecta of proteins
ironically i was too chicken to eat it
[Applause]
did you like it is it i loved it you did
somebody else cooked it for me right
exactly oh these will get delivered
right to your door sounds good um what
did you think of the potato chip
i loved the potato chips yeah this is i
could take a bag full
[Applause]
well if we want to wash down the tur the
duck or the onion we've got
something great to do it it's a turkey
and gravy soda
oh linda i'm a little nervous about this
one this is great for everyone who loves
gravy and potatoes but so tired of
chewing
it takes a little flavor it takes a
little while to
put the flavor in
yeah that hits you a little bit later
yes a little bit later
i'm going to say she finishes off real
nice
turkey and gravy soda is something i
never thought like a cream soda cream
soda yeah which i'm really happy about
yeah very good i'm actually maybe i
should just
[Applause]
um well linda i have to say it has just
been so fun having this feast with you
doing this segment and getting to meet
in person oh thank you it's my pleasure
and i've had so much fun to see both of
you thank you thank you
let's do another deer drew together
please
[Music]
you